رغم التقلبات الجويه والامطار الغزيره
والفيضانات اصرها هؤلاء السياح على اكمال
جولتهم في مدينه البتراء الاثريه الاردنيه
اخرون فضل التقاط الصور وتوثيق هذه
اللحظات رغم خطورتها
الامطار الغزيره تسببت في تدفق السيول وسط
المواقع الاثريه للمدينه
السياحي في نهايه المطاف من المنطقه
الاثريه باكملها
ليس بعيدا عن المواقع الاثريه للمدينه ادت
الفيضانات ايضا الى انقلاب حافله كما نرى
في هذه الصور التي نشرت على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
عام 2018 كانت مدينه البتراء من اكثر
المواقع تضررا من الفيضانات التي شهدت
البلاد وخلفت مقتل اكثر من 20 نصائحا ما
اجبر السلطات على اجلاء
3500 سائح من المنطقه واغلاقها وترميم
الاجزاء التي تضررت وفي عام
1963 جرفه الفيضانات المفاجاه 23 سنه
فرسيا عندما حصروا وسط المواقع الاثريه
لمدينه البتراء التي تقع على مسافه 262
كيلومترا الى الجنوب من العاصمه عامه